we now might know more about 2023's Call
of Duty game and it may be more of a
full-fledged title than previously
anticipated for the last decade yearly
Call of Duty games have been juggled
between three Studios that have led
development on each title Infinity Ward
Sledgehammer Games and Treyarch after
Sledgehammer Games Vanguard in 2021 and
Modern Warfare 2 by Infinity Ward in
2022. Treyarch was up next to bat
however in 2022 reporter Jason schreier
revealed that Treyarch's next rendition
of the franchise was internally pushed
to 2024 and that's 2023 would be the
first year without a Mainline entry for
nearly 20 years instead there would be
additional Modern Warfare 2 content
being thrown together by Sledgehammer
Games things have changed it seems since
that information came out inside a
gaming reports that this quote appears
to have been true at one point but now
Activision has decided to release a full
game albeit one heavily connected to
Modern Warfare inside a gaming went on
to reports that cards 2023 will have two
beta weeks and Early Access campaign
period and a full-fledged marketing
strategy in line with previous Call of
Duty games things could change but for
now inside of gaming reports that Cod
2023 will launch on November 10th with
campaign Early Access starting November
2nd beta weekends will take place
October 6th through the 10th for
PlayStation and October 12th through the
16th for everyone else the report says
following this news shria sheds some
light on the situation saying Black Ops
Studio Treyarch had planned to release a
new Call of Duty game in 2023 and in
early 2022 Activision delayed Trails
came to 2024 and instead opted to fill
in the blanks with additional
monomorphic content from Sledgehammer
now he reports Activision decided to
frame it as a full release considering
that last year's Modern Warfare 2 Broke
sales records for the record-breaking
sales franchise it makes sense that
Activision wouldn't want to put out
anything less than an experience they
could build as a package speaking of a
full package CD projekt Red plans to
walk back enhanced genitals featured in
the recent next-gen update for The
Witcher 3. the developer has stated that
the addition of a visible realistic
labia and pubic hair in The Witcher 3
next-gen update was unintentional and is
working on an update to remove the
features most of the game's romantic
scenes do not include full frontal
female nudity but the Brooks are enemies
and the crones from crookback bog in one
late game cutscene to appear fully nude
even in the original version of the game
while the original version obscured
genitalia with a barbie-like effect the
current version has more realistic
nudity why this inclusion was made was
unclear and when Kotaku reached out for
comment CD projekt Red replied quote
we're looking into it and will have more
information in the coming days initially
it seems bizarre that the game went from
having masked genitals to fully 4K
labias without the developer realizing
but in a follow-up email to Kotaku on
the original new it seems that their
inclusion was due to the extensive
Community mods that were implemented as
a part of the enhanced Edition what
Modern Warfare 2 spin-off game would you
like to see this fall from Sledgehammer
let us know in the comments and we'll
see you here for more Gamespot news
[Music]
[Applause]